it's a way of trying to put control of
how the network gets configured in some
sense into the hands of programmers
rather than just leaving it to a bunch
network protocols I've talked in the
past a bit about IP routing and you've
got the idea there that there's Reuters
which are computers that have multiple
network cards in that are interconnected
and they run some software on the
Reuters and the software implements a
particular routing protocol link estate
protocol whatever it might be
and so the software on the route has
exchanges packets with other instances
that software and they work out the
state of the network and they figure out
how everything's laid out and they work
out how to route through that network
and then when data comes in other
packets come into the network all
through just know what to do they look
at the packets destination address they
work out where to send it so it gets
towards its destination so that's kind
of traditional networking with Software
Defined Networking the approach is
basically is essentially saying that you
want to go from that quite distributed
control where you configure things but
then the protocols is run in the
background and work out what's going on
to a much more substantial eyes control
so you have software running which is
going to actually tell all of the
routers or switches typically it's
usually done at the lower layer things
so it's usually done at an Ethernet
layer rather than at my peeler they tell
the switches okay when you see this
thing this packet come in you should do
this with it and so it's much more
direct kind of poking everything
internet but poking all the rules in and
saying what should happen if you've got
a sort of traditional network you might
have a bunch of switches or breeders
have you wanna call them let's take the
case of Ethernet spanning tree there's a
protocol running called spanning tree
which designates that this is going to
be the root switch in the network and
then that runs a protocol to work out a
spanning tree so this is a structure on
a graph which is essentially the minimal
set of links that will allow you to
reach every other thing in the graph
every other node in the graph so in this
case depending on how the network set up
perhaps it would be that link would be
in that link would be in that link might
be in that link might be in and that
leak might be in so these two links in
that case would not be in the spanning
tree so there's a protocol that runs in
the background that maintains that
so one of these selected links say this
one would were to go down you'd end up
with maybe this one would come in so it
sort of responds to things like that but
all the switch is running that protocol
continuously in the background and
they're all kind of in some sense
they're almost running it independently
in that they're all doing their own
thing and participating this protocol
with the Software Defined Networking
firstly on each of these switches you
now have a piece of software running
which is able to control the switch I'll
come back to what exactly it does in a
minute and then you have another piece
of software which is called a controller
and this piece of software the
controller makes a connection to each of
these bits of software on each of these
switches there's obviously a bootstrap
problem here about how it gets to make
that connection given it's about to
control the network so that's a process
that's be gone through but basically you
end up with a controller able to talk to
each of these switches and then it talks
a protocol called open flow this is the
kind of the height what there are
actually two or three other alternatives
this p4 and puffs are two of them but
this is the one that seems to have got
out there in the industry and it's
actually supported by switch
manufacturers to some extent and
essentially you can insert into each of
the switches rules that say when you see
a packet coming in that matches this
each rule has got basically a match
clause and then it's got an action
associated with it and so it might be
that a match says well if the source IP
address equals 10 dot 0 dot 0 dot and we
want to drop it or it might be that it
says you know destination IP address
equals 10 dot 0 dot 0 dot - we want to
forward it out of port number 3 so it's
more explicitly saying to each of the
switches this is what you should do this
is what you do this is what you should
do in these particular cases so it then
becomes about explicitly managing those
rules and because this is a piece of
software here you can write whatever
sort of algorithms you want here to do
things in different ways or to treat
traffic in different ways each of these
bits of software running on the switches
that open for switch might have a
default rule that says if I see a packet
and I don't know what to do with it I
should send it to the controller so it
can then send the packets it's never
seen before - controller controller can
look at the packet and go oh this is
somebody trying to make a connection to
that web server I should put in a
rule that says that make sure that that
connection always goes through the
firewall or make sure that that
connection always goes through some of
the proxy middle box of some kind what's
the main benefits over traditional math
again it gives you more explicit control
so with these kind of methods either
with this sort of protocol or with the
IP routing protocols you essentially
control everything by setting weights
and then you allow the network to work
things out there's one way to think of
it in this case you control things by
explicitly saying what you want to
happen so you can and you you so you've
got that the ability to be more specific
about what should what should occur so
you can tell what's gonna happen
hopefully more easily in practice is a
very complicated network very
complicated rule sets in might not be so
simple but that's the kind of the map I
think part of the motivation behind it
spanning tree for example it's
essentially drop or forward out of a
particular port in IP routing it's drop
or fault out of a port and you do a
couple of things in passing so you
determine the TTL fields for example you
might check it checksum and drop it it
doesn't matter checksum but it's still
fairly simplistic with the controller
actions aren't just dropping forward or
forward to control it you can also
rewrite certain fields for example so
you might say well packet comes through
here with these details in the header
I'm gonna rewrite some of those fields
before I send it on you've got more
complex rule sets so you can with
certain with more recent versions of the
OpenFlow protocol you can start to chain
tables together this you say well here
is a table of rules and then if it
matches this rule it's going to go and
be processed by this table of rules and
you can build up state as you move the
packet between tables so as you as you
traverse through a sequence of tables
you can remember things about how you
got there essentially it's statistics
for example about how many packets
matched against which of these rules how
many packets how many bytes matched
against which of these rules and so
you're getting this kind of sort of feed
of information from it's an interesting
question there's a lot of research
interest in these kind of systems and
actually they go back to at least to the
ninth
90s there was work for example back in
the late 90s just around time I started
my PhD so I was done here in Cambridge
which was looking at how to do this kind
of control system for an ATM network so
that a synchronous transfer mode not
cash machines so but it was a very
similar thing where you'd have you have
some kind of layer of software on each
switch you have the ability for some
sort of control process just put
information into though into that
software to say what should happen when
cells came in on particular virtual
circuits that general idea has been it's
kind of been around for a bit and
there's a lot of interest in the
research community that's kind of waxed
and waned over the years probably the
biggest deployment that I know of that
is using this in some sense is Google so
for Google's Network they use that
apparently to manage their global
network to make it work in the way they
wanted to more efficiently than they can
achieve use into traditional kind of
protocols I guess it's yeah it's not
unlikely I don't know I'm not an expert
on Google's infrastructure but it seems
not unlikely that that's what happened
hopefully at least 200 more we'd like to
thank audible.com for supporting
computerphile if you go to audible.com
slash computerphile
you can sign up for a 30 day free trial
now today I'd like to recommend a game
of Thrones everyone's been talking about
the TV series but the books are
absolutely fantastic and what's better
is the graphics are all up here so that
makes them quite a lot better than TV
CGI in my humble opinion
I've inhaled the books and I'm waiting
with bated breath for the next one I'm
surprised I haven't actually recommended
these before as I've just worked my way
through them and just loved every second
of it so remember audible.com slash
competes file for that 30 day free trial
thanks once again to them for supporting
computerphile
the problem is that if I obtain a cookie
of you which is supposed to be secure
then I can send that to let's say Amazon
or to a shop and say I'm sure and please
you know what's in a shopping basket
what's his address
what's his credit card details